Before we dive into what
an orthographic camera is, and
how to work with it,
let's see one in action.
This demo creates a simple scene,
which you can view through
two different cameras.
The first camera just displays
an overview of the scene.
But the second camera, the close
up camera, you can move and zoom.
Give it a try.
So, once the demo's running,
you can use the arrow keys to move
the close up camera around the scene.
Now here's the interesting bit,
if you hit space,
you can see the scene
from the overview camera,
along with a blue rectangle showing
what the close up camera sees.
You can zoom the close up camera
using z to zoom in and x to zoom out.
What's really happening, is we're
reducing the portion of the scene
that's visible to the close up camera.
You can also change the viewport
height using w and s.
And the viewport width, using a and d.
When the viewport is wide and short, the
world looks super vertically stretched.
When the viewport is tall and skinny,
the world looks horizontally stretched.
You can hit f to set
the aspect ratio of the camera
back to the aspect ratio of the screen.
You can also rotate
the camera using q and e.
Be aware that very strange things happen
when you rotate a camera that's super
stretched.
Finally, note that you can easily zoom
the close-up camera out to the point
where it can see more than
the scene overview camera.
So, no matter how deep we get
into matrices and viewports and
what not,
remember that this is what cameras do,
determine what portion of
the world you can see.